después de los enfrentamientos y la
atención
llegó la calma para los ecologistas
franceses desplegados en León el motivo
por el que están allí y por el que se ha
manifestado este fin de semana es uno la
construcción del tren de alta velocidad
el león turín
estamos ante una emergencia climática lo
dice el ipcc y este tipo de obras solo
la del túnel base no estará terminada
hasta 2032 estamos hablando de décadas y
no creo que podamos esperar décadas
respaldado por la Unión Europea el
proyecto León turín se unirá con un 70%
de las líneas ferroviarias a francesas y
con un 30% de las italianas pero para
llevarlo a cabo es necesario un túnel de
más de 57 kilómetros Y es ahí donde los
ecologistas ven el mayor problema acusan
a que el proyecto tendrá un gran impacto
medioambiental con la destrucción de
ecosistemas de la zona alpina
franco-italiana en su de fensa el
gobierno de Francia asegura que la nueva
línea ferroviaria reducirá las emisiones
de gases de los vehículos pesados algo
que no acaba de convencer a los
ecologistas que aseguran que este flujo
está disminuyendo de por sí en los
últimos años Además del impacto
ambiental a los más de 26.000 millones
de euros de inversión Estatal también
han suscitado críticas